once again I have some crazy
relationship between x and y and just to
get a sense of what this might look like
if you plot all the X's and Y's that
satisfy this relationship you get this
nice little clover pattern and I plotted
this off of Wolfram Alpha but what I'm
curious about in this video is you might
imagine from the title is to figure out
the rate at which Y is changing with
respect to X and we're going to have to
do it implicitly we're going to have to
find the implicit derivative of this or
we have to derive this implicitly or
take the derivative of it implicitly so
let's apply our derivative operator to
both sides so the derivative with
respect to X on the left and the
derivative with respect to X on the
right so once again we apply our chain
rule the derivative of something to the
third power with respect to that
something is going to be 3 times that's
something three times that something
squared and then we have to multiply
that times the derivative of the
something with respect to X so the
derivative of this thing with respect to
X is going to be 2x that's the
derivative of x squared with respect to
X plus the derivative of Y squared with
respect to Y is going to be 2y times the
derivative of Y with respect to X once
again we're applying the chain rule
right over here the derivative of
something squared with respect to the
something which is 2y times the
derivative of the something with respect
to X which is dy/dx now that is going to
be equal to what we have on the right
hand side so we have a 5 times x squared
times y squared we can take the 5 out of
the picture for now take the 5 onto the
take it out of the derivative the
derivative of 5 times something is the
same thing as 5 times the derivative and
now we can apply the product rule so
it's going to be 5 times 5 times the
derivative of x squared is just going to
be 2x times y squared times y squared so
that's just the derivative of the first
function times the second function plus
the first function not taking its
derivative x squared
the derivative of the second function
well what's the derivative of Y squared
with respect to X well we already
figured it out it's the derivative of Y
squared with respect to Y which is 2y
times the derivative of Y derivative of
Y with respect to X so let me make it
clear what I just did
this is this and then this is when I
took its derivative so that is when I
applied that is when I applied the
derivative operator similarly similar
similarly that is that and when I
applied the derivative operator I got
that you want D the derivative with
respect to X right over there
so let's see if we can somehow solve for
dy/dx so I'm going to do on the left
hand side is I'm just going to
distribute this purple thing onto both
of these terms so if you distribute this
purple thing onto this term right over
here you get 3 times 2x which is 6x
times x squared plus y squared squared
and then if you distribute this purple
stuff onto this one right over here you
get plus let's see 2y times 3 is 6 y
times x squared x squared plus y squared
let me make sure 2y times 3 6 y times x
squared plus y squared squared and then
I'll keep the dy/dx in that green color
dy/dx is equal to is equal to well we
could multiply the 5 times this business
right over here and so everything that's
not a dy/dx term maybe I will do in
purple now so you do 5 times this stuff
right over here which gives you 10 X Y
squared and then 5 times all of this
right over here is going to be plus 10 x
squared y dy DX dy dy DX and I do that
right yep that looks just about right
and now we have to solve for dy DX what
I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract
this 10x squared I'm going to subtract
the 10 x squared Y
dy/dx from both sides n X 10 x squared y
dydx derivative that's not green
derivative of Y with respect to X going
to subtract that from both sides so that
I can get it on the left hand side dy/dx
and then I'm going to subtract this
business the 6x times all this craziness
from both sides so minus 6x times x
squared plus y squared squared let me
subtract it from here as well minus 6x x
squared plus y squared squared and what
are we left with what are we then what
are we then left with well these these
guys cancel out on the left hand side
right over here we are left with 6y
times x squared plus y squared squared
minus 10 x squared y times dy DX the
derivative of Y with respect to X the
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to these characters cancel out and
we are left with 10x Y squared minus 6x
times x squared plus y squared squared
and now if we want to solve for dydx we
just divide both sides of this equation
by this business right over here and you
get the derivative of Y with respect to
X and we deserve a drum roll now the
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to all of this stuff and I'm just
going to copy and paste it so let me
copy and paste it all of that stuff over
all of this stuff over all of that stuff
once again just going to copy and paste
it and I just have to draw the little
fraction symbol so we are done we have
figured out and it was kind of a hairy
expression but it didn't take us too
long what the derivative of Y with
respect to X at any point is so what
you'd want to do is if you want to say
hey what is the slope of the tangent
line right at
do this a color that you can actually
see what is the slope of the tangent
line right at that point well you'd want
to figure out what the x coordinate of
that point is so you could say what's
the you could say maybe the X is this
value right over here and then you could
solve for y to figure out what this the
y value would be and then you would
chunk it into that x and y into this
hairy expression right over here to
figure out the slope to figure out the
slope of the tangent line